Hình yện tâm emốt năm ngày thêm lập quân đội in dân Việt Nam, 2 tháng 12,5,5,5,5,5,5,5,5,5,5,5.
Chứ quân ngày 12,5,5, đoàn công tác đảng Ui, khô đồng in dân, vị bán như dân xả đông tiền 2,
tình lưu ý và chúng tâm con lai, BTVC Đã Tới Tham, chúc mừng cá nộ, chiến sĩ mộ tư lượng của một thải quân,
bong có vị chiến lượng đặc biệt, khoảng linh tựa bàn tự múng cả khoảng linh tựa quân viên.
Tại buổi gặp mặt, đai dịch đoàn đã hử lời tham hỏi và lời chúc mừng tốt tẹp nhất đến lượng hải quân,
những người con ưu tụi đang ngay đêm cây dữ chủ quyền biển đạo thiếu liên của tụi quân.
Những món quả ý nghĩa của những lời đồng viên trên thành lạ miền chim chất tình đoàn kết quân dân bên chặt,
tức thêm động được đều các chiến sĩ hoàn thành xuất sách nhiệm vụ.
Chỉnh đối đốc trên xin văn, chiến y vụ tư lượng của một đá bay tỏ sử dụng vật người lời cảm ơn sâu sách trước tình cảm của đế phương và xanh nghiệp.
Đồng chiến mại đai không chỉ là sự uống hộ về vật chất mà còn là ngôn của vũ tình thành tò lớn,
giúp cám bộ, chiến sĩ tưởng tại xuống nơi đầu sống hỏi ró.
Hóa đậm này không chỉ tôn vín chuyên tống về văn của quân đội mà còn tự nhiệt đạo liệu nước nhé hồn,
thách chất mỗi quan hệ gần kết dưới đế phương, xanh nghiệp ở đến việc quân đội.